You probably don't deserve to watch this
video. Your level is honestly too low to
watch this video. So, feel free to click
away from the video. But, for the few
who can handle responsibility, we're
building the only masjid in a village in
Norway. First payment is already done.
Final 500,000 remaining. Huge Sadaqah
Jariyah waiting. If you're serious about
Islam, you'll pause the video and you'll
click the link below to donate right
now. If not, enjoy the comment section.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing? And
welcome to another video, another
reaction video with the champ
that you like to watch, that champ that
you are addicted to watching, and the
champ that you
crave to watch. Yes. And if you haven't
already subscribed, then shame on you,
really, cuz this is where the discourse
is had.
This is where the conversations are had.
This is where it's at. This is where we
discuss matters relating to Islam and
Muslims in the West and everything else.
And today we're going to be speaking
about an individual as a far-right
individual called Liam Tuffs.
Yes, Liam Tuffs. Who, unlike his
surname, has actually got weak
arguments, weak arguments against Islam
and Muslims.
He had a conversation with an individual
called Brother Da'wah. Let's take a look
at a part of that conversation and come
back and respond in kind. The Prophet
Muhammad at 56 had sex with a
9-year-old. Okay or not okay? Fully
grown men do still have sex, rape
children. Do you think there's a link
between Islam and that behavior?
>> Well, let me go straight in with you,
Liam. Yeah, no problem. Straight in,
balls deep. The Prophet Muhammad at 56
had sex with a 9-year-old. Okay or not
okay?
Now, this is the number one
interrogation that people have against
Islam, I think, in recent times,
especially people from the far right.
And the response, the traditionalist,
conventional traditionalist response has
always been to say the following, is
this is anachronistic reasoning, this is
the fallacy of presentism, and that back
in the days almost every single state
and nation had puberty as the defining
factor, and that people were getting
married at 9 and 10 and 11, and even
your kings were getting married at that
time, and even your queens were getting
married at that time, and etc., etc.,
etc. And look at Delaware, and look at
these states in America where the age of
marriage was until 7 years old until
quite recent, and that this situation
has changed in the early 1900s, and all
of this
is a valid historical criticism that
almost any historical worth is
academic salt will accept. However,
because the laypeople are not like
academics and they don't understand what
you call the the thick description, what
Clifford Geertz called the thick
description of sociological and
anthropological phenomena,
these specious, spurious claims against
Islam are continually
iterated and reiterated. So, let's give
you another angle. Let me ask you a
question to start us up. The question is
this,
if someone
does not believe that Aisha was nine
at the consummation,
if someone believes
in the revisionist account, for example,
that she was 19, are they excommunicated
beyond the pale of Islam?
Is your understanding that believing
that the the Prophet Muhammad married
Aisha at that particular age
is an undercutter to the whole religion
of Islam?
Do you believe that this is an article
of our faith? Do you believe that this
is a pillar of our faith? Do you believe
that this is one of the Arkan, one of
the pillars of the Iman? No.
It's none of the above. And that's why
you actually find some traditionalist
scholars of recent times talking about
the plausibility of the revisionist
account that she could have been 18 or
19. In fact, you had this individual
called Abdul Rahman Kandahlawi who wrote
an entire book on the matter saying that
she could have been 19 years old and
explaining why, and you know, the Asma
argument basically stating that Asma
died at this particular time, and
chronologically she couldn't have been
this age, and she was 10 years
older than Aisha, and therefore Aisha
had to have been 19 at the time, and
going into details that we can't
actually go into right now because you
can read the book. It's actually
translated into English.
Another person is Sheikh Abdallah, one
of the most prominent scholars in the
world today. In fact, some could argue
the most knowledgeable one.
And this is what he had to say about the
matter.
Okay.
Now, as you can see here, all I'm
showing you is the plausibility of the
revisionist account. All I'm showing you
is that this does not take someone
beyond the pale of Islam. All I'm
showing you is that if you are using
this as an argument to undercut the
entire religion of Islam, it's a failed
argument cuz it's not actually something
we consider to be a pillar of Islam.
It's a historical thing. It's a
historical matter.
Amrun tarikhion. It is a historical
matter, and the scholars of the past
like An-Nawawi, Ibn Hajar,
and Ibn Ashur, and all of these
individuals say when it comes to
historical things, there's much more
lenience anyway.
And this is a mawquf hadith in Bukhari.
Yes, it is Bukhari, but it's mawquf. It
goes back to Aisha, and her. And so,
with there's more flexibility with the
situation. That's number one.
So, even if we went to two for the sake
of argument, hypothetically, no problem.
For the sake of argument, say
absolutely, you know, whatever.
Then you could say still that she was
19, and you could believe that and not
be you can you can disbelieve the fact
that she was 9 years old and still be a
Muslim. This is number one. So, it
doesn't undercut the entire religion of
Islam. You can still be a Muslim and
believe that she was older than that.
That's number one.
Number two, which is going to become
very detrimental for the likes of Liam
Tuffs who I saw recently was getting
baptized.
And of course, if he had a conversation
with me, he'd be intellectually
baptized. And that's a different thing
because I'm going to physically baptize,
yes, his friend Paul Golding in the
ring. Okay, I'm going to physically
baptize him. But, if you were have to
have a conversation with me, Mr. Tuffs,
you would be intellectually baptized,
and I'm sure that's why you
rejected such conversation with Ali
Da'wah in the past because,
you know, maybe you knew that there'd be
some questions that you wouldn't be
answer. And you're not in the the
position to be able to answer these
questions because, quite frankly, Mr.
Tuffs,
you're not educated. Quite frankly,
you're not qualified. Quite frankly, you
are not
academic. You have no background at all,
zero, in Islam, in sociology, in
anything. You are just a far-right
pundit that's repeating
uh talking points that you find on
social media. You have no knowledge of
your own. That's number one.
Number two, since you have been
baptized, I have a question.
My question to you is as follows.
If you believe
that the marriage of a 9-year-old is
wrong in all times and all places, what
do you do with the Bible?
Since the Bible in the book of Numbers
in the in the chapter 31, verse number
18, says that you can have the young
girls for yourself.
The tough in Hebrew, lahem, for the for
them. You can take it for themselves.
Like lahem in Arabic, actually. Lahem
and lahem are the same.
You can take the tough for yourselves.
You can take the young girls as
mentioned there in the Bible. And the
Babylonian Talmud and other biblical
exegetes, they all understood that as
essentially, you can take young girls
and have intercourse with them,
prepubescent, who have not known a man.
That's what's mentioned in your Bible.
So, my question is this, since you
believe that Jesus is part of a triune
God, okay, and that he therefore must
have been the author of the the Old
Testament, do you condemn Jesus?
Now, listen.
No running away here now because the
majority of people that are speaking
about this situation, yeah, are either
Jews or Christians. Let's just say for
the sake of argument, far-right
Christians. Since you're a Christian and
you believe in the Bible, yeah, my
question is this, since Jesus is meant
to be part of the triune God who
authored the Old Testament, my question
is simple, do you condemn your biblical
Jesus who commanded in the book of
Numbers, chapter number 31, verse number
18, yeah,
to take the young ones for yourselves?
Do you condemn?
No, do you condemn it?
Or you say, "Oh, that was for now that
was for then. This is the Old Covenant,
the New Covenant." But, he at one point
in time in historical timeline, he
commanded to that. So, do you condemn
that aspect? Oh, if you're going to make
a historical argument, it was okay then,
it's not okay now.
Then you can make the same argument for
for the Prophet Muhammad's marriage or
any other marriage.
Then you lost. You failed. It's a
dilemma. It's the Christian dilemma.
You're finished. You're done.
If you go, "Okay, well, actually, no, I
do condemn him." Then you're out of the
religion of Christianity. You're no
longer a Christian.
So, which one do you go for?
And how comes we don't find people
speaking about this verse the way they
speak about the hadith of uh in Bukhari
about the Prophet Muhammad and his
marriage to Aisha. Number one. Number
two, if you look at the book of
the First Samuel, chapter 15, verse
number three, where it says where it
goes to go to the Amalek and kill the
men, women, the children, okay, the
donkeys and the oxen, all of this the
children. Let's just focus on the
children for now.
So, killing a child is okay, is it?
Do you condemn Jesus Christ who you
believe is is an author of the Old
Testament because he's part of the
triune God. Do you condemn your biblical
Jesus, your Christian Jesus conception?
You condemn your Jesus Christ. Of
course, we wouldn't condemn Jesus. I we
believe he's a prophet. He's he's a
he is one of the greatest men who's ever
lived. But I'm saying your conception,
your Christian conception of Do you
condemn that conception? Who told us,
apparently, to go and kill the children?
Kill them.
You condemn it?
Oh, it's okay historically for at one
point in time for that to happen and the
the command to go into a
village and
them to ravage everybody and to kill the
children.
So, you see, it's going to get very bad
for you the more we speak because in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 22,
and you look verses like 28, for
example. You'll find that it's even
saying that someone who rapes a person,
he has to then
he has to then marry them.
Do you condemn Do you condemn Jesus
Christ? You condemn the Father, the Son,
and the Holy Spirit, all three of them,
for commanding that?
That somebody must be forced into
marriage with their own rapist or their
own rape the person raped them.
Do you condemn that? You see,
if you're going to go into a discussion
about the age of Aisha, and you're going
to go into a discussion about
prepubescence, and you're going to go
into a discussion about children and
stuff like that, trying to link Islam
with some spurious and specious claims,
as we've said, which can easily be
repudiated, then let's start with your
Bible. Let's start with the Old
Testament.
Let's start with the Old Testament, who
Jesus Christ, according to a Christian
conception,
co-authored, okay, at least he
co-authored this book with the Father
and the Holy Spirit.
So, what do you do?
What do you go say now?
And this is how we should respond
to these people. If they come from a
Christian or Jewish background, and if
they attack you with this interrogation,
don't go on the back foot. You can
answer quickly by saying,
"Frankly, this is not an undercut for
Islam or a start pillar of Islam. If we
don't believe, as Muslims, and this is
where it becomes quite If we don't
believe, as Muslims, that the prophet
married Aisha at that particular age, it
doesn't take us out of the fold of
Islam. But if you don't believe that
Jesus commanded in the book of Numbers
31:18 what he commanded, or the book of
First Samuel 15 number chapter 15 verse
number three, what he commanded there,
or the book of Deuteronomy what he
commanded in 22,
if you don't believe in that, that takes
you out of the pale of Christianity.
So, in other words, you're digging a
grave for yourself, and you're creating
a self-annihilatory
argument for yourself, a self-defeating
argument. And that's all I have to say,
and that is a KO blow,
a finish blow to anybody from that
particular background who wishes to ask
us questions about this. Wa salaam
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
Let's be honest, your contribution to
the world so far is a browser history
you make sure no one sees. Incognito
tabs, deleted logs, hours gone, nothing
built. Now, contrast that with this. A
masjid is being completed in a village
in Norway where Muslims have nothing. It
will stand for generations. Those who
donate will be remembered by Allah, and
those who don't will quietly return to
the shadows, back to the consumption,
secrecy, and absolute nothing to show
for it. So, do the right thing. Pause
the video, click the link below, and
donate [music] for your